So in the versions basis technique of learning concepts incrementally, we always
have a specific model and a general model. As a new example comes along,
we ask ourselves is this a positive example of the concept that we learned, or
a negative example of the concept that we learned? If it's a positive example,
then we generalize the specific model. If it's a negative example,
we specialize the general model. Here is another set of visualizations to
understand the specific and general models. This is a specific model.
This is a general model. The most specific model, matches exactly one thing.
The four legged, furry, black animal called Buddy. The most general
model matches everything, all animals. Here is a current specific model, and
as more positive examples come, you're going to generalize this specific model.
Here are some of the generalizations. Similarly,
here is the current general model, and as negative examples come, we're going to
specialize the general model, and here are some of the specializations.
As we'll illustrate in a minute, I'll start with the most general model and
try to specialize it. Some of these generalizations and specializations that
we are creating will no longer match the current data. When that happens,
we'll prune them out. As we prune on this side as well on this side, the two
pathways may merge depending on the ordering of the example. When they do merge,
we have a solution. The right generalization of the concept for the given
examples. So far we have been talking about this in very abstract terms.
Let's make this concrete with an illustration.